okay people joining this livestream we
are talking about how historical data is
handled in our knowledge base and its
interaction with both language
so first up here we seem to have the
history of the area of the Roman Empire
I assume though that so what I mean do
we consider this satisfactory what's
happening here or what what's going on
here this is a little weird
can you describe this so that this is
year - 27 right so it's not a data
object is that correct yes that's
correct
so it should be a date object and I mean
that input syntax is pretty horrifying
right I mean this is definitely not the
way it should look right who do we have
here I assume we have the relevant
people here so the idea here would be to
have a proper that a proper way to show
the data in this case or we have tried
here is to put just Paris that is the
year and then after that cure with the
polygon of the empire that certeyn and
that's certainly here actually so we
would like to see what else or how are
we going to put these things to work
with language so a suggestion would be
that this would benefit from a time here
too if it behaved as a time series
instead of just being a list well yeah
so I mean an analog of this is would
frequency data right um then here
in this case we're specifically
requesting a time series right and we'll
get a time series back hopefully this
thing is awake um but so in this case
this is a dated what is going on here
hey is a luminous Haley Chloe and I'm
here we also have Francisco here mm-hmm
what happened that I take a look on the
servers
I mean I'm running the preliminary
version here so who knows what's
happening but something looks wrong
there that's bad I don't even know how
the monitoring works I'm sure it's part
of the monitoring system you know
something is very bad here hmm this is
simply not working it's not to do with
some specific local or maybe we need to
get Roger here something is wrong here
look cloud of
it's not working yeah okay um somebody
needs to get okay do I need to do this
okay okay
well that's really bad but okay anyway
bit what this should be is to say you
know Roman Empire which I'm not going to
be able to do because it's timing out um
and then alpha goodness sake
this should then be you know dated
polygons and arguably the right way to
do this would be to have that second
argument with time series or
alternatively you know all could be
synonymous with that and that would
generate a time series that makes sense
to people yes doesn't make sense however
notice that that time series has to have
interpolation order 0 am I making sense
wait wired time series as a value for
dated
no look look that's analogous to this
case here okay
why why not all I mean that's the
typical thing for dated right I mean the
standard thing to get it to get a time
series of all the values with data than
anything would be all yeah I understand
does it give a time series typically yes
okay why is this not giving a time
series this is giving a list which is
wrong but this is this isn't in this the
fundamental point Rodrigo and everybody
else that time series doesn't you can't
we can't support a time series of
polygons yeah
the main issue here is that is us along
say a salon says we need to have a DSS
truck this has structure these property
and these results to work as time series
okay the problem was that that what's
the problem is the problem that time
series does not let you give lista
polygons is that the problem or is there
a different problem problems now we need
to compare that in so it works I don't
understand this is this it's trivial to
convert this to a time series unless
time series doesn't work with lists of
polygons and are you go asking me to
test that or what's the story here
now there are some is that it this is an
issue about time series all the folks
who are working on time series here
is it an issue about time series or
resistance to about something else
is is this a problem with time series
but don't we have Gosha and other people
here okay so fine so is this a problem a
time-series can we please answer that by
the way where are the notes from the
previous meeting
oh sure sorry we had we had Fatima last
time we have been this time he wasn't
able to join last time Ben I think you
were cc'd on the notes from from her we
can pass those back to Stephen so we can
look at those I mean we can we can set
up a meeting and discussed the issues
that you have if you have a new of
trying series but basically you can set
up interpolation order zero so it does
not mean your interpolate between the
polygons and if you have you know the
fields curve as ahead right it's gonna
understand and the values are symbolic
right so what is the problem guys
by the way Roger if Roger is here I mean
it's cloud Connect not working for me
oh now it is working okay so okay that's
an issue for between you and Warren and
those guys please figure out what was
going on okay you can see what was
happening here this was not working
right right yeah yep
and why did that not work although maybe
a completely different thing what what
what's that doing Francisco gonna have
to look at the server yes the virtual
servers is right now and restarting the
service I don't know why it's not really
reacting to the other productions
so someone on our call on livestream
says he's had minor problems connecting
to our infrastructure since January
first well gosh how could that be this
is all well monitored and you know this
shouldn't happen okay in any case um
okay so before you waste more time here
okay first of all why using this wacky
syntax here why are you not using this
syntax here
can somebody actually answer these
questions why are you not using that
syntax is there some problem with that
syntax
I learned there's a problem with that
syntax I'm not sure why they're being
slow to answer but I think they're just
using the fullest form of these
expressions I don't think there's a
reason not to do that okay um why is it
so slow Nick there's no caching for this
oh those the so generally the the dated
versions don't have specific caching
setup because as we change the date
parameters we don't necessarily know if
their cache trouble beyond you know so
the old version should be should be
cached yes and then there there are some
tentative designs to have an optimized
version where if you call multiple times
we basically behind the scenes call for
the l version and then have to if you
look up a specific time we can extract
from there but it requires a fair bit of
retooling under the hood so it isn't
beyond its prototype stages you know the
granularity is wrong here these should
have been data objects with the correct
granularity right with a year
granularity am I making sense yes we'll
fix that okay other than that this time
series seems to work fine what's the
problem what's the problem please guys
okay so that we want to use this as I'm
Kherson entity value or just callused no
I said it should return the time series
just like word frequency data returns
the time series and that's like what
other entities do when they're given
dated right right Allen yeah so I don't
understand what the problem is here this
seems like a no-brainer issue this seems
very straightforward now the question of
taking that time series and saying I
don't know what happens if we say is
there a how would I apply Geo area to
all of this I'm serious mom
so exactly fast is it okay
so let's say now if I say dateless plot
here that's gonna do that which is wrong
because it's gonna have I mean the the
you know since our data is really
stepwise now does that mean that as we
since we're generating since we have
control over the time series we should
generate it with interpolation order
zero does that make sense to people
yes but the plot solver right that often
so you need to use dates these step
thought no I well okay what do you mean
they override it ah that's wrong
shouldn't be the case
look if the time series has
interpolation in it then when you plot
that time series it should use the
interpolation that's in the time series
okay that's that's how it should work I
mean if it's doing something different I
don't think it's right so okay let's
let's plan to you know you can tell me
if there's some reason why that can't be
implemented but that seems like the
right way to do it
I agree okay fine so that's probably an
issue for Brett yes okay who isn't here
so you know can discussed it okay so
granularity has to be fixed time series
in has to be fixed interpolation order
has to be put in otherwise this looks
great
what's next to look at what's next guys
interval are the next area would be to
work with interval arithmetic which is
something nick has already been doing
and then we need to see sick away how to
add ice to polygons to you lookups okay
which we already treat on the previous
meeting okay
so would you please tell me what we
actually need to talk about I mean this
looks like it's it's under control as
well that this is I don't understand
what we're doing here isn't this
shouldn't this be using date interval
yeah that's the the I mean we're
planning on having a convenience of if
you have intervals of data
objects we will be able to convert them
to date intervals excellent
okay so there's nothing to discuss this
so let's move on okay
historical polygons to geo lookups we
already reviewed these from the previous
meeting
and we checked some things are so the
problem will here would be how to add
these to the geo entities that we to the
GL lookup queries that we have in
Mathematica so what we have here is
please go down how are we going to work
with the functions like you think you do
entities or G identify those are well I
understand I understand so this is so
you're saying you have a proposal for
this oh you do okay
you
yeah I think so I mean goe then Q is I
mean the the the thing would be
presumably so here's an interesting
question if you say geo position of I
don't know what you know London or
something okay we'll get the Geo
position and now if I say dated of that
geo position
you know 1252 or something um right now
that doesn't mean anything but I think
that that so there's a question of
whether that dated should go inside the
Geo position or whether it should sit
outside my feeling is it should work in
both cases so geo position can take a
time as well
am I making sense do you know that yes
worth element of the list right yes yes
that's right but this should be
equivalent to presumably that you know
this should be another form of that and
so if I say um so an interesting
question is yeah I mean this is a
reasonable question if I say is um
the you know
go ahead we could change that I was
wondering whether we would lose
readability because here the year is
very clear but the notation in your
position is based on you know I just
said I don't think we should change it I
don't think I think this should be
equivalent to the Geo position with four
arguments but I don't think it should
canonicalize to the Geo position with
four arguments unless we choose to
format the Geo position with four
arguments with a date object which i
think is also possibility what do you
think about that idea well my favorite
would be to immediately change to your
position because we have so many
functions suspecting geo positions now
generalize it then okay then what is
your response to my idea of having if
there's a Geo position at the time to
formatting that with a date you know
with a formatted date you get go and I'm
saying if I say look if I say geo
position
what do I if I say geo position of like
the International Space Station it
should give me a geo position with the
time correct yes yes okay so my proposal
is don't do this okay instead I mean
that's an absolute time thing but
instead at least for formatting that's a
little ugly isn't it I mean for
formatting give that as a date object so
we just types at the last element in the
list as a date object that's what I'm
suggesting I mean I'm not super thrilled
about that because you're telling me
that in terms of the actual meaning of
the Geo position I mean the fact is look
the fact is we really should teach
things that eat your positions to take
granular dates and things there because
we're gonna have trouble if that date is
not granular if that's an instant date
am I making sense
yes so the motivation here is that when
we have an array of these we want the
possibility of of providing numbers and
can be packed well that's fine but this
is a different case I mean look so I
think that the question of whether you
canonicalize to the for argument form to
me it seems like if you don't
canonicalize you still have a readable
thing and I would argue it's worth
looking at supporting dated of whatever
in the place of the cheer position but
maybe that's too hard I don't know okay
so those are the two cases but this is
clearly not an acceptable case right so
perhaps what we can do is whenever we
have four arguments we could show a
summary box and then we don't write
their work whatever we want yes that's a
reasonable possibility although I'm let
me repeat again that date needs to be
able to be granular I believe so we have
to store the granularity somewhere well
but then your position would not be an
event anymore would be something extend
it I mean that's what we can well okay
listen I'm not certain about geo
position naked geo position or
point-wise geo position okay look there
two issues with respect to this
historical stuff what we have here is a
point in space at a point in time that's
what it basically is right right then
there are other things which are an
extended object in space at I think the
set of things okay so your argument
would be the set of things which are at
a point in space but extended in time by
by granularity like your granularity or
something isn't really a meaningful that
will be your argument right in the same
way that we don't well we want something
extended in space we use polygons some
say that I know that your position with
fair enough okay fine okay but but still
okay so let's start looking at this geo
with NQ stuff and so on um
wait wait wait wait wait wait I mean
Seth is asking on a live stream about
the about a entity value and whether the
results will be different no they should
be the same they should both give a time
series I believe I'll put up above that
that that but let's go back to Jordan Q
okay um
okay so the idea here would be that how
we're going to treat joy thank you for n
it is that both have that both have a
time a date range such date range so the
idea here would be which times are we
going to use the NDP not they well let
me rephrase that
okay let me see if I understand okay
so Jill with in queue asks
is just to remind ourselves what it is
it's um if the location is contained
within the region right yes so
okay so for example Carl on a live
stream asks whether it's possible how
would we find all countries which have
them within the Roman Empire at some
time
- I'm askin ya that's one of the
questions we are going to try to cover
with these possible interpretations for
some of these queries okay so well
our first idea would be okay social we
treat these retrieved I and it is we
debated without with a year so the the
first query would be okay we get we just
retrieve the polygons for love each time
Monday and for each dated and then we
just evaluate from that so what about if
we don't use data so what does show we
think you for another example for the
query to the Roman Republic at Mount
Vesuvius was hit always had I understand
the question right so this is this is
this gets into our temporal logic
business yes um and I assume we don't
have yarn here talking to talk about
temporal logic I mean I remind me how
this would work with those those
temporal logic primitives that we maybe
Nick can speak to that yeah or or as I
could jump in I mean I think the
reasoning within temporal logic is that
were not you know with queries like this
we don't necessarily always have a
boolean answer you know what is Mount
Vesuvius contained within the Roman
Republic was false at some point cuz her
mom Republic didn't exist it was true at
a certain point and at another you know
defined point it was no longer true
right exactly how we would represent
that within something like a gia within
Q seems a little tricky I mean we have
the the same sort of overlapping
interval questions with you know deep
arithmetic of is is today there is now
before today we say well no that's an
ambiguous question it's contained within
the interval and we have a variation of
gia within Q for dates we have you know
date within Q and date overlaps Q to
sort of disambiguate between the cases
of partial overlapping which I think geo
within Q handles with an option right
Jose
yes yes I'm I was thinking that perhaps
here we could also use something like a
piecewise and then we just specify them
what is the string option fully
contained that's totally weird yes so
here the question is whether when we
compare a region to another region
whether we request that one is fully
contained on the other one or they can
be overlapping so so effectively when we
compare two regions that are like seven
different things like fully disjoint
touching overlapping contained touching
on the outside touching on the inside
all right
so listen this is the spatial logic
analog of the temporal logic we were
discussing excites basically the point
is geo within Q is naive and
unfortunately what we are highlighting
here is that we actually need spatio
temporal logic right we actually neither
spatial logic nor temporal logic is
going to be enough we actually need some
full spatio-temporal form correct yeah
so this is the especially complicated
case yes well it's good that we're
coming up with this case right now
because because we still need to you
know we need to loop back to the
temporal logic stuff oh boy okay so
what's happening with the geospatial
Statistics people and doing spatial you
know kind of spatial logic is that is
that going to happen as part of the
geospatial statistic stuff go sure can
you comment on that oh well yeah we we
have you know spatial statistics project
we have both said that so the Cartesian
coordinates know so support for the Geo
case no I understand that but I do you
are you dealing with this calculus of
within this so to speak
to some extent yes we have to because
when we compare you know observation
regions and whether the points are the
events happen in the observation region
or we want to take subsets yes okay so
we need this and we need this
functionality to answer many questions
yes
okay so right now okay so Jill within
cue has this hack for fully contained
which hopefully will be more properly
handled by the spatial logic stuff now
the question is what about the temporal
dimension of within queue what a mess
well for example the question that was
asked before which countries has have
been contained at some point in the
Roman Empire that could be handled with
G or entities if you said your entities
and we put the Roman Empire from
countries we could return the list
directly there well I understand but so
that okay so let me try out that case so
Jo entities you've talked about here oh
yeah okay so this is what Mountains were
in the Roman Empire so this works right
now oh here we go
look at this
so here you'd work it because we
requested with the full polygon of the
with the explicit volume as you can see
the dated of volume here that one
doesn't work right now no okay so that's
saying the giro entities us is pretty
nice actually this is pretty nice if
this work this would be really cool so
this is asking which countries as of
1500 were contained in with no or yes
are what is geo entities just joe
entities have the same containment
concept here contained in that region
does it have to be fully contained or
not
this okay so this has the fully
contained question and probably we
should promote that option to some kind
of um you know proper option not some
kind of weird string thing making sense
and it probably should be NGO entities
as well as in jail within Q yes it's it
was never documented because well well
it appears to have been documenting Joey
thank you which seems to be a mistake to
me yep
okay so we need an something which um
let's see so what you're saying is so
what would that be called that would be
called I mean that that's some kind of
thing that's like fully spatially
contained or something well maybe we
just can call it fully contained I mean
is that um I mean there's there's things
like contains there's a bunch of things
that are used for things like strings
and so on and I think this fully
contained business could apply to those
as well yeah and there are some
exceptions proposing the previous
section about simultaneously contained
or because you could apply also a
temporal logic to this contained right
well so are you suggesting then that
instead of a you know fully contained
true/false you're suggesting some kind
of
obtainment relation I don't know yeah
something like that
um but yeah I mean I agree containment
relation is some yes the problem is that
as I said there are many possible
spatial relations like not only
containment but also torching or
overlapping that maybe it's better to
more flexible way right
well you know I think we need to know
how some of the other design is going to
work okay so if we can get a separate
discussion going about whatever you guys
in the statistics area and spatial
statistics have come up with that would
be good and we need to combine that with
what we're thinking about with temporal
logic and see if we can come up with
something for this but for right now
yeah Gosha can you say something about
that design
I don't know yet I just have to look
into cases okay the the the the issue is
also for computational purposes
sometimes don't have with the you know
we use some kind of digital upset number
ice regions not sure so right so there's
an epsilon associated with makes is the
less than so in the and also how I would
have find you know the mesh or the
border over the four agonies and you
know the straight lines are not straight
and such yeah I know so it's complicated
right but but I mean I think okay the
question in what we're doing here are we
gonna run into the same temporal logic
is used as we're running into with
special logic here in terms of what what
is the simultaneous
I wrote true what is that about that
relates to the properties that we have
we suggest on the previous section those
are some ideas to try to narrow try to
find some ideas that we try to flesh out
on how the 3d containment
okay
well so what you're saying is I see okay
okay okay okay hold on okay so let's
actually read what you what you had here
okay so you're saying is Vesuvius within
the Roman Empire
yeah well that's the sort of
simple-minded interpretation the you
know the convex hull of the room not
quite the convex hull but the the
temporal outer hull of the Roman Empire
if I'm making sense right any any point
that was ever in the Roman Empire counts
as being in the Roman Empire
okay so hasn't two been
what does this mean has entity to some
split so that is that the Roman Empire
has evolved over the years so can we
take one of the any polygons or should
we take all the possible polygons of the
Roman Empire to do these comparison
taking one polygon seems very silly
that doesn't seem relevant I mean the
fact of the things pleasant to is not
and happen to be disjoint I don't think
that's relevant if that's what this is
about is that what this is about
I think so okay I don't think that's
relevant I think that I think it is what
it is which includes multiple polygons
if necessary
no no here they are splitting by by here
so in each year the polygons had a
different shape yes so what's your
question here so you are you asking
I see what is this interpretation - has
it always been within this thing or what
no if at any time it has been within the
Roman Republic or the Roman Empire the
Roman Kingdom in this case oh so it
wasn't in within the Roman Kingdom but
it was within the Roman Roman Republic
it's not true yep so the question would
be if if we want to interpret the
historical polygons they story tell
country to cover all the possible
polygons that enhance or only one let's
say the more extended which might not
cover all the polygons in his history
because he might have different borders
even if it's more extended so that was
the question here we want to interpret
that as if at any time at any point in
the time the whole history of this
country the point asked it like the
Vesuvius was inside there is this kanji
so like if I ask it for data at all for
the left hand side
I think the simplest thing to do here is
to treat if you don't specify a time to
just take all the polygons at all times
and compute the Union I consider that
that stay Roman Empire that the default
polygon for historical country though is
the maximum extent but it doesn't cover
all the possible balloons so it's the
polygon with the maximum area okay Oh
Union it's a specific selected largest
polygon right okay because the polygon
with the union of all the polygons which
will be of course computed it
specifically for such a lookup it's like
a very artificial polygon sometimes boy
okay so look there are clearly many
cases here and we have to parameterize
all of them we can't just pick I mean
there will be some default
interpretation but I'm not just gonna
pick one of these and say the others are
tough luck question but when you look at
the historical kingdoms like that
sometimes you see them up off like
they're the largest reach and that would
be the union of all the polygons
wouldn't it no no no because the largest
reach there may be regions that were
conquered later and we're not in clear
that's a dented but you know I happened
to run into a story in a few days ago
who who it turns out it's written a book
about country borders that I just got a
copy of that just came out and the
question is what is a country border it
seemed like the most plausible
definition was it's you know on
different sides you pay taxes to
different people or you that conscripted
into the armies of different people and
that seemed to be the most robust from
what I could understand the most robust
definition of of country borders but it
is a country borders or a strange thank
God sorry what we don't say i just holy
[ __ ] your passport
in modern times haven't existed possible
to only existed like 150 years maybe I'm
sure I guess the successor accessibly
existed for a lot longer
toys existed forever validation may be
the defining feature of that I don't
know um okay so do you think that once
we parameterize all these cases maybe we
should then pick which one will be the
default
um in my opinion if you just specify a
date then you know which polygon it is
if you don't specify a date and you want
to do this type of computation you just
compute with the union of all polygons
because any other choice seems random to
me sorry say it again
yes I think when we use data it we can
either specify a given date or say all
so when we have a specific date then we
know which polygon it is yes when we say
all I think we should just compute the
union of all the polygons so we have and
compute with that because any other
thing if we choose the largest spend or
the latest or something like that it's
it's going to look on them when you
request the polygon we tend to devalue
right now we are the largest yes with
that I agree but when when you say all
somehow you are asking for all at the
same diagram yes but when you don't say
anything then you're like defaulting to
one that's that was my question what
will be their very fault when you don't
say
[Music]
that item that the largest case seems
fine
in that case but but not when you say oh
yeah I agree that all should cover all
the things that's right we do we need
other named geo variants to specify for
these
oh that's an interesting idea it's
exclusive of dated right we're talking
about other ways of selecting other
forms of a thing that are not
necessarily tied to maybe because for
example if you want the Union polygons
of all the time that cool we consider
different values or a very specific
polygon flavor well okay let's just
survey what we have to figure out here
so that there's I like the idea of using
geo variant for something to do with
this um oh boy there's a lot of stuff
here so okay there are cases that we can
definitely do
and what on earth is the simultaneous
thing doing
that's a proposed option to say for if
we are going to compare entities at the
same time in this query we have joined
it is for military conflicts that happen
in the Roman Republic space we would
simultaneously say ok so current
military confident happen at the time of
the Roman probably during the dot same
time span sorry I said it again
so with simultaneous we are narrowing
down temporarily the military conflicts
to the time span of the Roman Roman
Republic you don't know when the Roman
Republic existed but you want to find
out what military conflicts
occurred in that
totally weird word I mean that's
basically the natural dated period geo
entities here this is asking for the
Roman Republic over I mean this is
asking over the full course of the Roman
Republic okay the point is the Roman
Republic is a thing in space and time
and geo entities could represent the
spatio-temporal thing here and this
would then ask since military conflicts
have both a space and a place and time
this is asking what is the intersection
of you know military conflicts with the
spatio-temporal region that is the Roman
Republic
am i making sense
yes doesn't make sense right so I don't
think you ever need this what would you
want to do you know if you want the
Roman Republic in a particular year then
you say it otherwise this is the full
spatio-temporal Roman Republic well you
mean so in military modern-day military
conflict that occurred military
conflicts from some other period that
occurred okay so I mean that would and
not be simultaneous it will be cannot
and poor rainiest if it was anything but
I don't think that will really work and
I don't even know how to spell
contemporaneous contemporaneous I think
um that doesn't look right but anyway um
uh okay the you're saying how do I find
a modern military conflict yes that's
interesting well I think that then what
you have to do depending on what the
defaults how the defaults are set up you
would say dated well what is modern
I mean military conflict happened at
summertime so unless unless there's
something very right if I say um you
know let's say twentieth century or
something that's the only thing I would
basically be saying there and by the way
that granular case should work okay what
I'm saying dated with a granular date
object should work I don't know if it
does right now
can somebody check that whether that
works and I don't see what you were
trying to do I I said 20th century
so I'm saying there's a dated with a
granular date object so the question of
whether a thing with a so for example if
I say would frequency data okay of word
, and then I say 20th century yeah this
is a resolving something like a century
to an appropriate date an object in the
language which is no no
that's not the issue the issue is
whether this returns a time series or
whether this returns something different
because a specific year this will just
return number to go what I'm saying so
with this particular case when it's a
granular thing that is above why doesn't
that work
oh no why doesn't that work
- oh I know I know yeah I know I know
it's doing its that's not right that's
not what it yeah it has a date spec
after the time series so that's it
that's at that case is already um you
know almond itself against this issue
but you understand what I'm saying that
that if you say I mean maybe maybe I can
do this right now for something like
this if I say something like um okay if
I say um UK and then I say dated
population comma that thing there okay
okay but that was fine except for the
non-linearity of the of the years that
worked just fine that did exactly what
it should have done however if I would
put in their date object of 1901
you
you
okay that gives a specific number that's
a little weird okay what I'm saying that
a date object which is granular gives a
time series but a date object which is
singular at least at the on the distance
scale of this particular data set gives
a single number did you get what I'm
saying what would you like I think in
the case of population our sampling rate
may not be much more than annual but its
annual annual but what I'm saying is so
this is a case where I'm getting a
number that is because we're down at the
sampling level then I'm getting a single
number but if I go to something which is
still a date object but with a coarser
granularity I'm getting a time series
well what we had before was an interval
so the granular date is not the same
thing as the interval fair enough but
I'm saying with a granular date what
should you get perhaps with a granular
date we should always get a number some
sort of average of that period and then
if we want the actual time series we
specify a time series which is an
interval between two possibly let's
think about whether that would actually
work I mean that would at least be
consistent I think okay but so have the
method of you know with with state
interval you'll be able to say date
interval of a granular date and turn it
into the specific period in time so in
principle we're trying to make the
transformation between a granular date
which is you know a low resolution in so
a low resolution so what Jose is saying
is that the low resolution thing would
basically imply an averaging over that
region rate whereas the date interval of
that granular region would turn into a
date interval which would imply a span
over that region which would then be
filled in with the time series seems to
make sense to me
yeah could you go back to the military
the Geocities military conflict case I
just grabbed my head what if I wanted
all military conflicts of any time that
fall within the borders of the Roman
Republic is it just military conflict er
that dated all of military States at all
okay I would never think that the
default geo entities Roman Republic
military conflicts would default to
assuming military conflicts within the
date span for which the Rouen that's
what I'm assuming that I have to admit
that I don't completely understand all
the semantics of that I think this is
this is Francisco's question by default
the entity should be some specific
moment perhaps the largest spent and if
you want all the moments you should
specify date at all because when we have
an entity it I find that it strange that
an entity represents a food period of
time well that's a spatiotemporal entity
the question is is a historical country
a spatio-temporal entity because I mean
clearly we have temporal entities the
Elizabethan period for example is a
temporal entity actually also probably
implies some spatial information as well
but but that's a temporal entity
whereas Italy is a spatial entity and
historical country could be a
spatiotemporal entity that makes sense
or we can decide I I think it really has
to be a spatio-temporal entity then by
default most of the properties would do
it on time series that's what I think
yes
unless you specifically say dated unless
you project the historical country by
slicing it at a particular time with a
dated
I think that's going to be the most
sensible way to do this potentially
require very large amounts of data
well that we have to think through but I
mean like for example
oh my gosh I mean it's great that we can
do this jirô entities 600 BC why do we
have to say polygons there so it's just
a inversion right yes so the idea is to
improve this do not need the polygons
there okay okay but this also what if
that was building well in that instead
of Mountain Kingdom yes spread we need
to two things but are also themselves
well I guess mountains are well if we if
we had a comparable to a degree but
we're talking about different timescales
yes
right so you're saying a building is
another spatio-temporal entity a
military conflict
it's another spatial-temporal entity
although an individual battle is
presumably mostly a point in time and
for the data we have a point in space
you
well this is already
oh boy yeah okay so a dated object the
position of a dated wrapper around a
building before the building existed
should surely give missing
this is complicated oh boy
okay but by the way you guys are working
on leader data I hope this is nearly on
the language integration of leader later
right yes that's there are some question
we have for integration of their data
and what is the question here really so
the idea we have here is that we already
have our leader data entities as tenures
as a mixture of a point of a person at a
certain moment in time at a certain
jurisdiction and with a certain
government position so having their
sector four things here so do we want to
have the entities as that a topple of
those four things we want to have them
as 10 years to help to make lookups we
want to help them as for instance our
identity called barack obama president
of us or well Donald Trump president of
us do we want an entity called president
of the US and then we have dated that
then that and those data will show
anything in multiple kinds of entities I
think what we I think the 10 years as
you're calling them of you know the
particular time that so-and-so was you
know Steve Jobs was CEO of Apple twice
right so yes those are two different 10
years in your sense and probably should
be different entities but yet the
position so I claim there are three
things
there's a person Steve Jobs there's a
position CEO of Apple and there's a
tenure Steve Jobs as CEO of Apple you
know from 1978 to 1984 whatever it was
five whatever
okay correct so your clothing is EEO of
Apple a single entity or is it is there
a position than an organization because
we also have organizations
you
no I think it's a position in an
organization now I'm not sure what
happens if there are co-ceos
we could just return a data list yeah we
can just go with the whole thing and
then we pull out a data list and then
return to results for that case or
whatever people we have what if somebody
is a co CEO for a while and then they're
an individual CEO we might have any the
instances for that in that case so we
can put our specific points of time
because for each of them differently
maybe and what if there are an interim
Attorney General or something and then
they've come
how does that work we do have also
forever and for every tenure or every
literally 90 days we have we already
also have a property called positional
status so we can cover for acting
interim Regents unlikes we can even have
one for Co governments to say okay so we
have a bunch of people here
okay
oh boy
okay there's some complicated stuff here
we're not going to be able to resolve
this today um I think the main thing is
the realization that we need some kind
of spatial temporal logic stuff and it
seems to me what we should aim to do you
know we will have a partial
understanding of how that will work in
general but we should try to understand
what the default cases are going to be
hmm okay yeah I mean we're gonna have to
meet again about this um yeah Alan do
you think the do you think um progress
can be made without me or do you think
we should um
um I think progress can be made without
you on a number of fronts here I think
we're gonna we were already gonna meet
again soon to look at the computer data
related stuff because we need to do some
search migration but we can come back
with pieces and this is this is a lot to
fold into one thing I think they're up
there are separate things we should peel
off into different meetings and
follow-ups yeah I mean this is a very
complicated kind of knowledge to deal
with um if you're right the overall
spatio-temporal handling though is
something that
would crap up in a lot of them
I'm thinking that's right and I mean one
question is whether the region are
whether the whole region framework can
handle four dimensional regions I think
it can count it yes I think it's going I
mean if we can handle the spacer case
then time is just another dimension
right and that's what I suspect we
should be doing here is we should be
thinking about region intersections and
things in time and the question is
whether whether we can have a reasonable
representation you know if we try to
take the Roman Empire for example and we
try to make its four dimensional
regional specification with all the
meshing and all that kind of stuff can
we actually do that because it will it
will get meshed in the time direction as
well oh yeah yeah yeah right
yes good point it's two plus one
dimensional space-time right so you
interpolate on there it's not
interpolation it's going to be the
zeroth order interpolation in the time
direction it's gonna be the stepwise
interpolation right that's what we
believe is the most is the you know
change and hold type interpolation right
now yes yes that's interpretation we
agree right yeah okay all right
okay listen I have to have to run off
here but but um very interesting thanks
to folks on the livestream and to be
continued